it didn't work
I think this is this has been a good
exploration into not only how bad we can
make the graphics look but also how long
we can last until we get banned hey guys
welcome back to potato mode the show
where we take the best looking games out
there and just turn the graphics into
absolute mush and this week we have a
very much requested game the only
problem is I've never played this before
so instead we have our own jake decker
here to play some Rainbow six siege this
week
hello I'm not that good so if you
haven't seen the show before what we do
is we take the games running at their
their best and then we slowly but surely
turn everything the graphics into
something that's not not pleasant well
I'm dead so this is not very exciting
the one thing about siege is that the
environments or a lot of the
environments are destructible right yeah
pretty much well almost everything if it
looks like it's brick or like this
that's not gonna break yeah I should
have switched to this shotguns gonna
show that off but like here so lots of
opportunities for like little effects
and dust particles and all that smoke
yes
barbed wire oh no grenade ran into a
grenade we've seen the good amount of
the game running at its high saying so
let's let's go down a notch pretty
simple just turn it all the way down to
low let's play let's see how far down we
can we go all right so we're good do
some terrorist hunt here rid ourselves
of all the the other players and just go
with all NPCs I guess yep you know what
at least for my on my monitor we're
looking alright okay you can still
recognize the stuff like this is clearly
a police vehicle alright
so a very good amount of just
destruction still still intact
Wow I went flying forward by that guy
okay I punched open the window shot me
from behind and he exploded it alright
so well I think I think with that I
think your punishment is gonna be even
lower resolution here conveniently I
already have the the window open right
here so it's under my documents game
siege and basically the not sure what
that is but that's the the latest folder
in which holds the the game settings
okay and in here you have like all the
graphics options and whatnot
but what you can also do here is this is
our previous resolution setting so we're
gonna go 320 by 180 and while we right
let's turn the resolution scaling down
to 5 because why not this is all what
I'm supposed to play with this will be
fine I feel like you underestimate your
abilities at least I can like do other
things yeah really tiny in the corner
you want you can do your taxes in on the
left side oh my lord
Joey this oh oh cool one of my favorite
maps this is what it would be like if it
came to Game Boy Advance yes oh my got
the camera I'm sure some people would
enjoy a challenge like this right no no
one would
okay I'll have mercy on you so as you
may have noted earlier we only have two
operators right we have two operators
operators and the reason why you have
two operators is because we are playing
on my account someone who has never
played the game before
we're not playing on Jake's because of
battle I which is Ubisoft's like anti
cheat thing which prevents hackers
cheaters and anyone looking to reduce
their graphics in-game further than they
should that's what the cheaters are
always trying to do reduce the graphics
and because of this I had to do a little
bit of code cracking or to get the game
working up to snuff for the show I'm
gonna win this round if we win this
round we win the game okay how about
this if we win this round I put in Oh
fie the game but if we lose it
I have to well I'll still put a leaf out
either way but you're gonna have to play
it with the 5% scaling oh no your faith
is in your hands Jake
it's in my team's hands I've never been
smoked before this is the first smoke
whoo we won yeah we won I don't have to
plan a three inch screen okay and I got
a kill
lucky you as you can see right here we
have the Nvidia profile inspector which
does a whole lot to remove the textures
in the game but it's difficult to get
that to work with the Rainbow six siege
unless you do a couple of things so what
I'm gonna do first is I'm gonna turn on
the usual settings that we use for the
the show and over here we have a folder
which is in the the program data section
of Windows and what we're gonna do is
we're gonna hit apply to these changes
and these two things gonna hit read-only
so it doesn't actually change them once
we go into the game and just just a note
before we jump to the game please don't
do this at home or if you want to just
please be very very careful you might
get banned and okay that doesn't look
good all right Wow look at that I want
use as my next wallpaper well explore
some of the map a little bit I'll
probably die while exploring it that's
fine got a little private room here let
me try to go around a little Oh God did
you see the blood though I'm almost dead
do we have a doc oh great we do have a
doc doc you me god oh no oh my god I
took out two he said that was depressing
if only he knew what I was dealing with
right now but now we're outside so we
can get a nice picturesque view of the
outside world I was playing with one of
our news news video producers Matt
Padgett and he was saying all the maps
in this game reminder of ps1 level like
maps just cuz it's like warehouse yes
they feel like ps1 Maps now they like
look like now they actually RP as well
now
should our vision be obscured right now
well actually I don't know
are we cheating I feel like we were just
a game changer if we can't see the smoke
Jake I think we may be cheating I'm
gonna see if I can switch to a smoke
grenade okay then we can test this out
my teammates are gonna be very confused
when I pop a smoke right at the
beginning but for science all right so
that smoke is still there you have
perfect vision though I wonder if we
change it to the resolution all the way
back up would it be even more of an
advantage like that well that was the
luckiest kill I've ever gotten
look it was it was all look it didn't
work we can go one more I think one more
I think this is this has been a good
exploration into I think not only how
bad we can make the graphics look but
also how long we can last until we get
banned I suppose I can do this oh god
they shot me from under the ground
well it was it was a valiant effort I
think I think before we leave let's
let's take a look at the operators at
least alright give them give them like a
nice little shiny moment in the
spotlight you know what I don't know if
we can look at them since we don't have
them unlocked
well we can take a look at the ones that
we that we do have who's like the
largest out of all of them oh I know who
we should do I know who we have to do
who shall go I hear you guys talking
about them all the Lord to chunk I guess
we got it we got a sneak peek I look it
let's look at ash first okay that's bad
there's ash and then
[Applause]
he's so gloriously can you see his eyes
from here they're like just barely maybe
change his headgear to that I like the
patent nice he's creeping me out I don't
like him we're opening up our pack
there's supposed to be something here oh
cool all right let's see what we get
legendary let's go I love it
alright I think that about does it then
for this episode potato mode if you have
a game that you'd like to see potato
fight just like we've done here make
sure to leave in comments leave it on a
message in Twitter on Twitter with
Twitter and make sure to tune in next
week for the next episode of potato boat
Jake do we have any money to buy
anything at the shop here we are
basically broke or basically broke but
that's ok we can always buy this
wonderful potato mode shirt instead that
you can get on the GameSpot shop right
now it has a wonderful illustration done
by a very talented geo law of a nice
little potato relaxing on the beach
watching his favorite episode of potato
would most likely get one now know
someone took the hood operator we have
I'm gonna tell them my only operator I
think I said that if I just well no
matter what we're gonna say back to you
maybe they'll know next time that not to
pick these